bonsoir 11 mois pour convaincre pierre
bérégovoy le nouveau premier ministre a
peu de temps devant lui l'année
prochaine en mars 93 les français
voteront à nouveau
feront ils confiance aux socialistes
tout dépendra de l'action de pierre
bérégovoy qui a sans doute pensé en
prenant ses fonctions à pierre mendès
france dont il était proche
pensez à la durée trop brève du passage
au pouvoir de l'ancien président du
conseil
elle avait eu lui aussi peu de temps
pour convaincre pensez également à son
style pierre bérégovoy sans les
manifestement inspiré en choisissant la
discrétion
l'humilité même pour ses premiers pas de
chef de gouvernement albert ripamonti
bercy 22h45 le nouveau premier ministre
pierre bérégovoy qui ces anciens dur au
15 juillet plus tard sa voix sur
s'engouffre sous le porche de l'hôtel
matignon
après un bref entretien avec son
prédécesseur et discret centre pierre
bérégovoy prend la direction de la
maison de la chimie ou les socialistes
tiennent leur journée parlementaire
il espérait cette nomination ils sont
enfin soulagé 15 heures le premier
ministre se présente à l'elysée
c'est la première visite du nouveau chef
de gouvernement au président l'entrevue
va durer 45 minutes à l'issue desquels
pierre bérégovoy rejoint le palais
bourbon pour assister à l'ouverture de
la session de printemps à l'assemblée
demande 17 minutes plus tard le bois là
au sénat là encore pour un déplacement
éclair
17h02 nouveau la cour de l'elysée la
journée du tout nouveau premier ministre
est déjà longue mais elle est loin
d'être terminée françois mitterrand a
donc donné à la france un nouveau chef
de gouvernement mais toujours pas de
gouvernement ils continuent de consulter
jérôme cathala oui paul ainsi roland
dumas robert d'intel actuellement jean
louis bianco se sont entretenus avec le
président de la république mais aucun
n'a fait de déclaration alors en
l'absence d'informations depuis ce matin
tous les journalistes guettent les
allées et venues des uns et des autres
mais là aussi il faut se méfier ainsi
jacques attali l'ancien conseiller
spécial du président de la république
est bien venu ce matin à l'elysée mais
il n'aurait rencontré que son ami hubert
védrine l'actuel secrétaire général
lisez en ce qui concerne la composition
du futur gouvernement
aucun horaire n'est pour l'instant fixée
demain après demain ou encore ce soit
bien tout est possible on insiste en
tous les cas ici sur le fait que le
gouvernement sortant expédie les
affaires courantes
en tous les cas le président de la
république lui tu n'en néglige pas pour
autant ses engagements prévus de longue
date
il a ainsi reçu comme vous allez sans
doute le voir sur les images il a ainsi
reçu pendant plus d'une heure les
médaillés olympiques des jo
d'albertville et des jeux paralympiques
edgar grospiron carole merle ou encore
fabrice guy il a loué leur courage et
leur goût de l'effort
courage et efforts autant de qualités
que pierre bérégovoy devra sans doute
avoir pendant les onze mois de son
gouvernement
merci jérôme devinettes donc arlette qui
partirent est écoutée on est sur à peu
près du départ et même certains maires
du départ de lionel jospin auquel aucun
autre poste n'a été proposée par tôt si
ce n'est pas une surprise philippe
marchand riz nallet et jean poperen
doute sur le maintien de louis mermaz
qui pourrait aller à la justice doute
aussi sur le maintien de michel
delebarre en revanche resterait monsieur
dumas qui partagera son ministère avec
michel vauzelle promotion pour jack lang
éducation jeunesse peut-être pour
monsieur landes ou jeunesse et ville
bernard kouchner aussi aurait une
promotion avec un grand ministère de la
solidarité de la santé resterait jean
louis bianco mais à un autre poste
éducation finances paul quilès que l'on
voit aussi à l'intérieur et aux finances
ça fait encore beaucoup de points
d'interrogation et martine aubry qui se
bat pour rester au travail
mais en voulant obtenir un certain
nombre de garanties entrée spectaculaire
dont on parle
bernard tapie et harlem désir
reviendrait aussi monsieur badinter
parmi les nouveaux ségolène royal une
marque pour ce gouvernement si ces noms
se confirme la marque de laurent fabius
certains disent même que si tous hélas
se retrouver au gouvernement ce serait
un gouvernement faible
le dernier carré en attendant de
constituer son équipe pierre bérégovoy
sait qu'il dispose précisément donne un
atout important
la direction du parti socialiste le
soutien et l'ambiance des journées
parlementaires du ps a en effet basculé
en quelques heures ce qui demandait hier
avec insistance le départ d'edith
cresson ont accueilli ce matin avec
satisfaction pierre bérégovoy au portage
de daniel sportiello et claire germouty
pour être attendu il était attendu à en
juger par la bousculade et pas seulement
par les journalistes les parlementaires
socialistes étaient en effet soulagée
d'avoir enfin au bout de deux jours de
travaux un nouveau premier ministre car
tous étaient unanimes sur la nécessité
d'un changement à matignon après
l'avertissement donné par les électeurs
un soulagement doublée d'une grande
satisfaction pour laurent fabius pierre
bérégovoy fait partie de son courant et
le premier secrétaire du ps a été le
premier à le saluer
voir et
toute son équipe bonne chance pour la
au ps on attend aussi une politique
sociale plus ambitieuse que pierre
bérégovoy est à même de pouvoir réaliser
estime temps compte tenu de la confiance
que lui accordent les chefs d'entreprise
et les milieux d'affaires
une nomination qui soulève de nombreux
espoirs donc continuer une bonne
politique
pour la france pour le franc et pour les
autres économies et d'autre part mener
rapidement
les réformes sociales indispensables qui
nous ont fait défaut au cours des
derniers temps il va parler tout petits
du chômage et tout ça va l'aider et
korité que nous a parlé de justice
sociale
langage commun
jean pierre chevènement le député maire
de belfort est lui plus sceptiques qui
peut pas demander un nouvel élan s'est
fait mal et reste bloqué
même temps les marches ne sont pas
infinies
un an c'est au vu du calendrier
électoral le temps que se sont fixés les
sociale il faut tenter de redresser la
barre accueil chaleureux de la part des
parlementaires socialistes mais
attentisme pour ne pas dire plus
dans les autres parties critiques à
droite bien sûr où les leaders
politiques affirme que pierre bérégovoy
n'est pas l'homme du changement
critiques à gauche aussi où le parti
communiste n'accordera pas a priori sa
confiance au nouveau premier ministre
jean baptiste renamic l'a observé à
l'assemblée nationale pour une rentrée
avant séance express
à l'assemblée l'opposition ronge encore
son frein elle attend aussi de connaître
le gouvernement et si on dit respecter
l'homme bérégovoy on commence à planter
des banderilles en forme de petites
phrases d'un événement un ministre un
premier ministre socialiste succès d'un
premier ministre socialiste la dernière
traversée
l'homme était monté à bord
ses qualités
certainement fallait arriver à matignon
du père la rigueur qui va faire sortir
le peuple de gauche de son coma et comme
on est cool et communiste s'interroge
sur la future politique gouvernementale
ce premier ministre qu'on considère un
peu comme un des fers vaut l'hostilité
cette nomination n'est pas de bon augure
pour l'avenir réticences exprimées en
séance mais pierre bérégovoy restera
silencieux car à 17h foot est terminée
rendez vous pour la déclaration de
politique générale tout le monde rentre
même que la rumeur a déjà nommé mini
pierre bérégovoy devra donc user de ses
talents de diplomate et de négociateur
pour séduire et la classe politique et
les français
mais c'est précisément pour ce talent là
que françois mitterrand l'a choisi
prudent mais déterminée pierre bérégovoy
est en effet un fidèle du chef de l'état
il a gravi les marches du pouvoir pas à
pas et sont arrivés aujourd'hui à
matignon et la consécration d'un fils
d'ouvriers dans un milieu d'énarques
bernard sega pierre bérégovoy le pinède
à gauche l'homme du franc fort et de
l'économie de marché mais d'abord le
fidèle entre les fidèles toute sa
carrière et dans l'ombre de françois
mitterrand il fut des 80 secrétaire
général de l'elysée l'homme clé du
nouveau président alors que pierre
mauroy est désigné comme premier
ministre
bientôt il deviendra ministre des
affaires sociales avant de succéder en
juillet 84 à jacques delors rue de
rivoli au ministère de l'économie des
finances
neuf ans plus tard après la cohabitation
il retrouvera encore ce ministère
déménagé à bercy un ministère qui
deviendra progressivement un état dans
l'état
au point que dans le gouvernement
d'edith cresson six ministres pas moins
seront placées sous son autorité
pierre bérégovoy aura réconcilier les
français avec le monde des entreprises
redonner confiance au patron à la bourse
et maîtriser surtout l'inflation
ce fils d'une famille modeste est un
socialiste convaincu ajusteur fraser à
16 ans cadre de jazz offrant devenu
maire de nevers il ne pensait pas à
l'époque sa carrière dans la politique
quand j'avais vingt ou trente ans ce qui
l'a trahie 30 ans
je ne pensais pas à je ne sais quel
destin politique je militais et
socialistes qui sait compter est
néanmoins un pragmatique il sera sans
doute amené à desserrer d'un cran la
rigueur concilier masse riches et les
revendications sociales
pierre bérégovoy premier ministre
émirati le pierre bérégovoy ministre de
l'économie et des finances à cette
question le successeur d'edith cresson a
en partie répondu aujourd'hui il prendra
qui l'annoncé des initiatives
audacieuses contre le chômage
une façon implicite de dire qu'il
tiendra compte du vote du 22 mars et
qu'il donnerait une couleur sociale à
une politique jugée trop molle est à
risque jusqu'à présent les points forts
de la politique des réseaux voix c'était
bien sûr la lutte contre l'inflation et
la défense du froid une politique qui
lui a apporté les louanges des milieux
d'affaires et du patronat
son point faible effectivement le
chômage ses amis socialistes lui ont
souvent reproché claude guénin c'est sur
le chômage qui monte à la verticale vers
les 3 millions que pierre bérégovoy a
été le plus contesté à l'automne dernier
son départ avait même été évoqué dans
les rangs du parti socialiste du côté
des syndicats la politique de rigueur du
ministre de l'économie finissait par
agacer plein ralentissement de la
croissance on exigeait de lui un plan de
relance qu'il dessert les cordons de la
bourse pour stimuler le bâtiment la
consommation et créer des emplois
pierre bérégovoy n'a pas bougé il n'ya
pas d'autre politique économique
possible a été sa réplique
finalement il a dû se résoudre à
accroître les dépenses de l'état d'une
cinquantaine de milliards
mais même en hausse le déficit français
reste l'un des plus faibles du monde
juste après le japon sur le fond sa
politique n'a pas varié la lutte contre
l'inflation et restait sa priorité
la france réalisant l'une des meilleures
performances mondiales mieux que
l'allemagne une maîtrise des prix qui a
permis d'améliorer la compétitivité des
produits français
la balance commerciale point faible de
l'économie est même redevenue positive
depuis quelques mois ferme sur les
grands équilibres économiques on accusé
pierre bérégovoy de négliger le problème
du chômage
deux options se présentent maintenant
pour le premier ministre soit il ne
change rien à sa politique fidèle à lui
même soit il profite de son image
rassurante dans les milieux d'affaires
pour desserrer la rigueur et combler le
déficit social dont on l'a accusée et
déjà les français réagissent dans un
sondage réalisé aujourd'hui par csa pour
radio-france et le parisien libéré les
expriment un sentiment globalement
positif sur l'arrivée de pierre
bérégovoy à matignon
ils rejoignent en cela l'opinion des
milieux financiers en fait lundi snap a
bondi à la bourse le marché restait en
légère hausse il faut dire que les
financiers s'attendaient à l'arrivée de
pierre bérégovoy des financiers
confiants et rassurés
reportage au palais brogniart de
laurence mobilier et louis aubert plutôt
aux pieds la bourse à l'ouverture les
marchés c'est en hausse mais attention
interprétation abusive
la nomination de pierre bérégovoy était
attendue et l'activité du jour est au
ralenti on n'y a pas de réaction
particulière le marché avait largement
anticipé sa nomination par conséquent
c'est
rien de spécial rien de particulier et
hier soit madame cresson rentrer à
l'elysée le marché monte des cadres
sortait sans rien dire ça mais c'est
tout le monde attend maintenant une
première décision et de voir quelles
orientations à prendre le gouvernement
et pas seulement un nom je te monde
attendait il arrivait de pierre
bérégovoy provoqué peu de réactions en
revanche le départ d'edith cresson est
largement commentée vous avez dit à
venir et donc été un non événement
tu t'es sympa cresson par son tour et si
on était resté qu est ce qui se serait
passé
je pense que la bourse a salué par une
belle baisse comme l avaient fait leur
sa nomination probablement pour
retrouver ce niveau quelques temps après
qu il faut bien avouer qu'ici on n'est
pas prêt d'oublier la petite phrase
d'eric triton la bourse
j'en ai rien à cirer et chacun pense en
fait que pierre bérégovoy aura plus
d'égards envers les milieux financiers
qui lui accordent déjà leur confiance
quant aux syndicats ils font preuve
d'une grande courtoisie à l'égard du
chef du gouvernement
il salue son arrivée mais lui demande à
l'image de la cfdt de lutter plus
efficacement contre le chômage et sur ce
point ils sont unanimes bérégovoy la
rigueur devra devenir bérégovoy le
social s'il veut obtenir leur appui
réaction de marc blondel de force
ouvrière et jean kaspar la cfdt
l'entreprise qu'il fallait lever les
contraintes les contraintes budgétaires
et les contraintes économiques que se
fixer lui même le ministre des finances
et je les accusais de faire une
politique de rentiers or la politique de
rentiers on ne peut pas la faire
durablement
il ya un moment où il faut redonner le
mouvement et je compte sur l'expérience
de bérégovoy pour que maintenant en
voulant affronter les véritables défis à
commencer par le chômage
ils étaient obligés d'aller vers une
politique de relance tout cela dépend
des positions que prendra monsieur
bérégovoy mais la fonction peut
également modifier des comportements si
le premier ministre ne comprend pas que
l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est l'emploi et
le social
alors il est évident que le gouvernement
se plantera et que les français à juste
raison se poseront la question à quoi
ont servi ces élections qui accordera
servi un changement de gouvernement et
les nouveaux venus dans le paysage
politique ne s'embarrasse pas de
précautions les verts et génération
écologie refuse d'entrer dans son
gouvernement
la situation n'est pas mûr déclare
antoine waechter la voix est trop
étroite affirme noël mamère la famille
écologiste est apparemment sur la même
longueur d'onde
l'attenté la prudence wernig aurel y
aller ou ne pas y aller
les verts ont tranché pour les amis d'un
tiers la nomination de pierre bérégovoy
est le symbole d'une politique de
rigueur mais surtout l'absence de
réponses claires à leurs exigences et
chivu pour eux à une fin de non recevoir
le point de rupture c'est très
probablement
absence de contrat clair entre un
éventuel gouvernement et les verts dans
ces conditions a effectivement nous ne
participerons pas au gouvernement il est
hors de question de le faire sur des
rumeurs sur des promesses sur des choses
très vague
sans contrat écrit il n'y aura pas de
regrets même attitude du côté de
génération écologie les amis de brice
lalonde estime que les conditions
d'entrée dans un gouvernement ne sont
pas totalement réunies pour répondre à
l'esprit d'ouverture qu'ils appellent de
leurs voeux
le paysage politique français a éclaté
je crois qu'il est temps pour les
grandes familles politiques
traditionnelles et en particulier pour
la gauche auxquels notre coeur est
attaché il est temps de réfléchir et de
s'engager dans la réforme et de
l'ouverture
c'est peut-être encore un peu tôt nous
attendrons aujourd'hui génération
écologie et les verts se retrouvent dans
le refus commun de participer à un
gouvernement avant de se retrouver
peut-être pour un projet plus
constructif edith cresson coditel ne dit
rien du moins publiquement que
pense-t-elle elle aurait beaucoup à dire
fernand tavarès voyez en tout cas ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que pour edith
cresson la nomination de pierre
bérégovoy à matignon même si elle a
décompressé bien ça encore du mal à
passer ce soir
alors ce matin le tête-à-tête entre
l'ancien et le nouveau premier ministre
on sait comment il s'est déroulé très
tendue dit on ce soir à matignon et puis
il ya cette lettre de démission quand
vous voyez le premier ministre président
de la république sont contenues sous la
vème république est assez dur et décret
sont indique bien qu'elle n'a pas pu
gouverner par ce canal est un
gouvernement restreint et solidaire et
l'indic surtout qu'elle n'avait pas la
solidarité explicite des principaux
responsables du parti socialiste est
justement edith cresson ce matin l'avait
pourtant bien l'intention d'aller les
voir ces députés les sénateurs
socialistes pour leur expliquer un petit
peu son point de vue elle n'a pas eu le
temps de le faire
le président de la république a pris
acte effectivement du parti majoritaire
et de sa décision et donc elle accepté
tout de suite la démission d'éric
cresson alors ce soir à matignon et bien
c'est encore un petit peu d'amertume et
du cresson rencontre ses principaux
collaborateurs
on a fait une photo de famille cet après
midi dans le jardin on s'est embrassés
on a même versé quelques larmes et puis
tout à l'heure à 20h30
edith cresson organise un grand launch à
nouveau pour tous ses amis
en tout cas le premier ministre sortant
sera encore demain à matignon
car la passation de pouvoir est prévue
exclusivement pour samedi matin voilà
donc ce soir pour l'ambiance où
finalement on a dit qu'aussi qu'edith
cresson à l'intention de ne pas se
rendre à châtellerault tout de suite
elle attendra encore quelques heures
une dernière information elle compte
quitter ça c'est une toute dernière
nouvelle compte quitter la politique
certainement qu'elle rejoindra
l'entreprise privée dans quelques temps
là au moins précise-t-on encore on a su
apprécier ses talents
c'est dans cette dernière information
est révélatrice edith cresson ne se
remettent pas d'avoir subi aussi
brutalement les conséquences de la
défaite socialiste des précédentes
élections
elle n'a eu que dix mois pour convaincre
jamais un premier ministre on avait fait
un séjour si court à matignon pendant la
cinquième république
dix mois au cours desquels les obstacles
et les oppositions même au sein du ps se
sont accumulés jusqu'à son départ ce
matin michel lemaire il y a dix mois
pour la première fois sous la république
une femme et de mes à matignon françois
mitterrand est à la recherche d'un
nouvel élan pour sortir les français des
brumes de la morosité
edith cresson est chargé de l'incarner
l'opinion accueille plutôt favorablement
cette nomination mais l'effet cresson
est de courte durée
il est vrai que le nouveau premier
ministre est venu à matignon pour faire
le ménage comme elle le dit prendre s'il
le faut des mesures impopulaires pour
assainir l'économie est préparée 93 elle
veut convaincre en travaillant sur les
dossiers concrets plan pme pmi
apprentissage délocalisations mais rien
n'y fait la météo les sondages
n'annoncent aucune embellie pour avoir
de bons sondages c'est pour gouverner
ses propres amis ne lui facilite pas
toujours la tâche il rapports sont
parfois tendues avec le parti ou le
groupe socialiste même s'il s'appelle
l'espace d'un congrès à l'approché des
élections elle retrouve son style
militants pour partir en guerre contre
la droite et surtout le front national
mais quand elle exhume les symboles
socialiste distribution de roses au
rythme de theodorakis l'opposition qui
lui aura mené la vie rude livre une
dernière charge
la regardais je me disais vraiment il
avait choisi avait voulu avoir ma dame
de fer cette visite est madame thatcher
quand on est socialiste et ils sont
tombés sur une sorte de causette des
misérables nouveau pourtant elle quitte
aujourd'hui le devant de la scène en
ayant le sentiment d'être resté fidèle à
ses convictions et à son image
je crois qu'il faut déranger dans une
certaine mesure si on veut que les
choses avancent ou alors il fallait
mettre quelqu'un d'autre il ne dérange
pas si vous nous rejoignez à l'instant à
19h55 je vous rappelle donc la nouvelle
du jour pierre bérégovoy a été nommé
premier ministre mais le gouvernement
n'était toujours pas formé peut-être le
sera-t-il pour soir 3 à l'heure de soir
3 les autres informations la libye n'a
pas apprécié les menaces de sanctions du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu elle l'a
fait savoir à sa manière
plusieurs ambassades étrangères ont été
attaqués à tripoli par un peuple en
colère je cite les autorités libyennes
face à ces incidents le conseil de
sécurité s'est aussitôt réuni en urgence
à new york
la france et la grande-bretagne ont
demandé que le nu protestent
vigoureusement ce soir le calme est
apparemment revenu à tripoli philippe
pisteurs l'ambassade de france cible de
protestations spontanées comme sont
spontanés plus devant les caméras
officielles toutes les manifestations
depuis ce matin contre les
représentations diplomatiques de
plusieurs pays ayant voté les sanctions
contre la libye
tellement spontanée que les forces de
l'ordre ont dû s'interposer que si l'on
en croit un afflux l'agencé officielle
libyenne
il y aurait même une dizaine de blessés
parmi les manifestants malheureusement
toujours selon jana la colère populaire
n'a pu être partout contenus par la
police
résultat l'ambassade du venezuela
heureusement l'évacuer détruite par un
incendie
rien d'une réaction spontanée parce que
le venezuela présider le conseil de
sécurité lors du vote des sanctions
contre la libye
j'ai demandé une réunion d'urgence un
conseil de sécurité
une réunion qui vient de commencer nul
doute
que l'onu devrait émettre une
protestation vigoureuse déjà les
occidentaux s'inquiétaient les
tracasseries bienne canton visa de
sortie
même si la libye sous lui prête des
dommages et le venezuela et à lui
présenter des excuses officielles
tripoli semble bien pour l'instant
décidé à montrer sa mauvaise humeur
isabelle thomas résume les autres
événements du jour le procès de foi des
lignes salah s'est ouvert aujourd'hui à
paris ça leur est accusé de la vague
d'attentats qui a frappé la capitale de
décembre 85 à septembre 86 faisant 13
morts et plus de 300 blessés sept
magistrats siégeront pendant les 15
jours que de procurer le procès trois
défenseurs ont été commis d'office à
l'ail aurait puisé son avocat maître
vergès
le chef présumé de l eta militaire a été
inculpé d'association de malfaiteurs et
de détention d'armes et de munitions par
les deux juges d'instruction parisien
chargé du dossier
art à palau a été transféré à paris sous
bonne escorte du pays basque où il a été
arrêté dimanche
le rpr jean paul de rocca serra a été
réélu président de l'assemblée
territoriale corse au troisième tour de
scrutin
âgé de 81 ans ranca serra président lé
parlement corse depuis sa création en 82
sous forme d'assemblées régionales
d'abord puis l'assemblée territoriale
retour de mission pour les sept
astronautes d'atlantis la navette
américaine s'est posé à 6 heures 23
heures locales à cap canaveral au terme
d'une mission de neuf jours qualifiée
d'historique par les experts de la nasa
les scientifiques de l'espace rapporte
une moisson inédite d'observation des
mécanismes de l'atmosphère et du soleil
et la ville de paris a encore gagné
il faut dire que le bateau japonais a eu
une avarie il a dû abandonner
didier valaize moral au beau fixe pour
ville de paris un bateau en progrès un
équipage qui peaufine sa condition
physique
pourtant tout a failli capoter dès le
début de l'épreuve systématiquement
depuis les demi-finales le départ est
capital or une mauvaise manoeuvre
pénalise le défi français est contraint
celui ci à faire un demi tour laissant
filer l'adversaire nippon toujours à la
recherche de leur première victoire
les japonais prennent le large chris
dixon possède même 30 secondes d'avancé
à la première poupée et plus d'une
minute à la deuxième on craint alors
pour marc pajot que les positions ne
soit définitive
en effet déjà battu à trois reprises
dans les premières régates
on se pose beaucoup de questions à bord
et puis coup de théâtre dans le s final
disputé sur une mer agitée par un vent
ayant fort si à plus de 16 noeuds les
japonais sont contraints à l'abandon
après 2h30 de course
un incident mécanique affecte le
gouvernail nippone serait t'il
fragilisée dans des conditions plus dur
possible
quoi qu'il en soit ville de paris
poursuit sa route sans problème n'ayant
qu'à franchir la ligne d'arrivée pour
marquer un deuxième point essentiel pour
la suite de la compétition et les deux
voiliers s'affrontent à nouveau ce soir
en direct sur l'a3 à 12h40 avant cela
soir 3 à 22h35 présentée par marc
hautement et dans quelques secondes la
météo de planches la bonne soirée sur
l'a3 bonsoir à demain 19h
on
je peux